I think yeah I sure lied uh I watched
the video yesterday I didn't realize
there was a three minute video I thought
yeah sure only put out 20 seconds so
that was my mistake and then I did watch
the video and I think yasher Ali lied
about the context and is trying to
manipulate the framing to make Steven
Crowder look as bad as possible well
there is this one quote at the end where
he says something like they put up the
quote on this forget if I'm gonna F you
up I think but they say it's off camera
and we just the most damn in claim we
sort of have to take their word for it
and by the way yeah sure I know this is
aside the point but he went into hiding
for like a year because there was some
Daily Beast article about him where it
came out he was like couch surfing and
like Kathy Griffin's couch and wouldn't
leave like just bizarre stuff with this
guy so he's not uh the most credible guy
now look at you know changes the clip or
anything but uh just I don't know
another guy I think could be getting
that much attention in the first place